I am currently a testing engineering
manager and I support the material
mechanical testing in my role I manage
multiple projects the course in project
management through UMass has really
helped me enhance my overall performance
at work
hi I'm Lisa Lou Casey my expertise lies
in developing fast effective and
relevant strategies I was in the medical
device industry for 15 years
one of the projects that I'm very proud
of is the development of wound dressings
for severely bleeding injuries for the
military we were able to get the second
fastest FDA approval and awarded the
2004 top 10 greatest army inventions
career growth is not an option without
great teams taking this project
management course was an opportunity for
me to develop those skills
the program consisted of five parts
upon completion of this course I was
able to pass my PMP through the project
management Institute and my agile scrum
Master certifications upon the first
attempt
my favorite part was the Capstone
project at the end this gave me the
opportunity to apply my learnings
practically and this is very useful for
my current role
I've struggled with mental health
challenges throughout my life and sports
have been a way for me to work through
those challenges
as an adult I started taking karate with
my daughter
and earned my black belt when I was 40
and my second degree black belt when I
was 45. I have co-authored two books
focusing on the mindset of athletes the
first one is maximum composure
and the second one is Lucidity in sports
and this year we have a new book coming
out when I am encouraged and supported
to embrace my diverse skills and
experiences I'm able to tap into my
superpowers as a fast learner adaptable
team leader
as a mother of two my greatest dream is
for my children to find their
superpowers
and create a Wonderful Life and a better
world for everyone around them
like me they are excited for what their
future holds